whereas which ellipse is represented by
the equation X minus 4 squared over 16
plus y minus 1 squared over 49 is equal
to 1 and we're given a bunch of choices
here we're given 4 choices here so let's
just think about what's going on here so
the center of the lips is going to be 4
comma 1 how do I know that well the
equation of the ellipse is going to be x
minus the x-coordinate for the center
squared over here over the horizontal
axis horizontal radius squared plus y
minus the y-coordinate of the center
squared over the vertical radius squared
so the center is going to be 4 comma 1
so the center here is not 4 comma 1 the
center over here is not 4 comma 1 not 4
comma 1 the only choice that has a
Center at 4 comma 1 is this one over
here so we already know this is this is
the choice without even looking at the
horizontal and the vertical radius but
we can verify that this works out
because a horizontal radius right over
here notice it goes this orange line
which represents can represent the
horizontal radius it has a length of 4
and so the horizontal radius is 4 and so
we see indeed that 16 is the horizontal
radius squared this is 4 squared and if
we look at the vertical radius here we
see it has a length of 7 we're going
from y equals 1 to y equals 8 has a
length of 7 and we see in that equation
that this indeed is 7 squared so that
was pretty straightforward